Let's go back to our original model,
the hotel_log1.
This is where we threw all
the predictor variables
into the logistic regression trying
to predict that redeemer field and
now what we're going to do is
throw in a step wise tool.
The step wise tool takes one input from
the logistic regression model object and
the other input from our
original estimation data set.
We now need to name what
we want to call the model
which I'll call stepwise_ log for
a logistic step wise regression.
Now as you can see like
we mentioned before,
there's different search directions.
We can either use a backwards and
forwards search or a backwards only.
By default, I'm going to choose the
backwards and forwards in combination.
Now before, remember, we mentioned that
there's a couple different ways to
determine that best of the step wise
model when it should actually stop and
that's off of this AIC,
or the BIC values.
AIC is generally accepted as a better
measure of model quality than BIC is,
but however,
the BIC is available to be used as
a quality measure if you want to.
But the AIC is selected by default,
so I'm going to keep it as that.
If you want to read a little
bit more about these,
you can find some information about the
AIC and the BIC in the reading notes.
The last thing I'm going to do is I'm
going to bring in a browse tool after
this step wise regression report output.
Now we're going to click run and
we're going to view the output.
Now what you can see in the results
is we have a very similar result
that we saw in the logistic regression.
As you can see, we removed the income
field and the customer segment field,
yet we kept the large
categorical variable of region.
If we go to the bottom, we can see that
the r squared is quite similar to that
we saw before in the full logistic
regression that we just ran, yet
we reduced many different
variables from this overall model.
We still have many different variables
that are still statistically
insignificant, since they don't have
those stars over on the right hand side.
Now that you see how easy it is to
build out a step wise progression,
I'm going to ask you to build one
out yourself in the next section.